i thought it wasn't gonna happen at
first man you know what i mean like
if it goes a lot goes into getting
traded
i'm feeling grateful um
anxious but at the same time i know what
i got to do
coming here without helping the young
guys
um playing as hard as i can and for one
thanking two
years he was the first overall pick in
2008 after one year memphis his third
year in the league he won the mvp
hurt himself that devastating knee
injury
and the playoffs of his fourth year but
the first seven years with chicago
and then came the one year in new york
clyde
what do you think is the most important
thing that he brings to the knicks
well right there his quickness
ability to score create havoc off the
dribble
and uh when he's healthy he's he's a
very good player
injuries have derailed his career so if
he can remain healthy i mean he's a bona
fide player
eric spoelstra before the game was asked
about him and that's exactly what he
said clyde the
the quote was when he's healthy he moves
the needle
and spoelstra said do not underestimate
the partnership between thibodeau and
rose he said when a player and coach
have that trust factor
and when they're on the same page and
know each other so well it really can
make a difference in the players
production
well because you're going to give 110
percent for that
that coach like i did for red host
respect was there and all the players
you heard of
thanking kids but yup for getting me out
of detroit
tom thibodeau when asked about it had a
lot of things to say we'll we'll discuss
it as the day goes on
rose with his first shot rolls off won't
won't go fight for the rebound nerlins
noel
and the put back but always asked about
him clyde and he said well
he says i like good players he's a good
player i'm partial to good players
nick's up four one guy who likes this
new back court of quickly and rose is
john calipari former memphis and current
kentucky coach
and quickly realizes it's part of him
meshing now with rose
we both played for the same coach in
college so you know we share some
similar experiences there
playing for a tough-minded coach and
then you know we both get
coach tibb's rookie years so a lot of
similarities
you know i'm looking forward to you know
just getting the chance to pick his
brain
uh something i like to do is just ask a
lot of questions and you know get
feedback put take notes and all
things like that and i got a chance to
talk to him last night at dinner
a little bit he just stressed to me you
know he get first of all he gave me his
number
you know he said anything i need just
hit him but he sat down with me a little
bit me and obie actually
just told us you know he's here to help
us he's here to help us grow
things like that having veterans around
to help young players
is one of the more underrated parts of
the game tubes knows that
he brought him in right he knows if that
was an ob
topping